hey guys dr. Burke here in this video I
want to share with you the most common
cause of a b12 deficiency but let's just
talk about what b12 is it's an essential
B vitamin that you must get from your
diet and what it does is it makes these
little things called nucleic acids which
which are the foundational genetic
material for yourselves so basically
they make the foundation of red blood
cells white blood cells and myelin what
is myelin myelin is the outer covering
of your nervous system and it allows the
conductivity of nerve impulses to travel
when you lose myelin you have all sorts
of electrical problems pain problems
nerve problems pain and mass all sorts
of things so that's what happens when
you're deficient in that but you can
also become fatigued pale memory
problems dementia Alzheimer's
neurological issues like peripheral
neuropathy would even with like--that's
foot pain or hand pain anemia kind of
you're completely you know there's
there's something called pernicious
anemia I'm not going to get into that
what it is but it comes from b12
deficiency but most b12 deficiency does
not come from necessarily diet it comes
from the stomach not being acid enough
low stomach acid okay because it takes a
very strong acidic stomach to absorb b12
into the body and a lot of people have a
problem with the pH in their stomach
normally a pH of the stomach should
between one and three which is really
really acidic the way you know you have
a low stomach acid is you have acid
reflux GERD gas bloating because the
stomach is needed to be able to close
the valve that just protein absorb
minerals like calcium iron all these
different minerals one third of everyone
over the age of 65 has a b12 deficiency
but they all will also have a low
stomach acid problem so it's a really
simple solution to fix a big problem
so what do we recommend apple cider
vinegar okay
apple cider vinegar pills or just go
ahead and start drinking with your meals
with some water with a little straw and
that will create some really cool
changes for a lot of people just by
adding that one little thing in there
and you know you don't even need to take
more b12 you can just go ahead and
acidify the stomach and a lot of things
clear up and you start to absorb b12 so
it's a real simple simple solution now
to build the stomach acid you also need
a certain healthy salt like in sea salt
because a lot of times when you're low
and sea salt the acid goes down also you
need potassium comes from the vegetables
so you need potassium to build the acid
also iodine so you do need these
minerals as well so if you're taking
anti acids or you're just eating poorly
or you're not taking enough minerals
eating healthy you will lose the stomach
acid and then you start having a problem
with it so it's a whole chain reaction
okay so go ahead and plug this in as far
as to fix this and see how much better
you feel write your comments below and I
will see you in the next video